[Musik]
jetzt live aus köln
der presseclub mit jörg schönenborn
herzlich willkommen an diesem
sonntagmittag schön dass sie dabei sind
gestern morgen beim einkaufen auf dem
wochenmarkt trage ich einen stamm
zuschauer und er fragte freundlich
lächelnd was ist denn das thema am
morgen und als ich dann wahrheitsgemäß
sagte sechs monate krieg in der ukraine
wurde das lächeln etwas steif er
überlegte einen moment und sagte dann
höflich ja da muss man auch mal wieder
darüber sprechen es war am mittwoch
genau sechs monate her dass der
russische überfall auf das land begann
in den ersten wochen haben wir jede
bewegung jede nachricht jeden
abendlichen brennpunkt mit schrecken
aber auch mit großer neugier verfolgt
inzwischen ist unsere bereitschaft
vielleicht auch unsere fähigkeit
verschwunden uns jeden tag neu damit zu
beschäftigen andere probleme wie
gaspreise rezession und andere steigende
preise beschäftigen und stärker und wir
verdrängen gerne wie viel das eigentlich
mit dem krieg zu tun hat auf dem
schlachtfeld passiert seit wochen ja
täglich sterben menschen aber was das
vorrücken und zurückweichen angeht wenig
die fronten sind festgefahren und
deshalb versuche ich heute mit klugen
gästen zu eruieren wie kann die wird
dieser krieg weitergehen wer kann kann
ihn überhaupt jemand gewinnen unser
thema heute sechs monate krieg in der
ukraine part an der front
kriegsmüdigkeit im westen und das sind
unsere gäste ich freue mich auf kerstin
münstermann sie leitet in berlin das
parlamentsbüro der rheinischen post
christoph schiltz ist bei uns
korrespondent für welt und welt am
sonntag in brüssel nah dran an nato und
eu
wieder bei uns ist andreas zumach
langjähriger korrespondent in genf heute
freier journalist in berlin herzlich
willkommen und ich freue mich auf alice
bota außenpolitische korrespondentin für
die zeit früher lange korrespondentin in
moskau auf roboter sechs monate da ist
so der reflex halbzeit das ist ja eine
frage die uns wirklich beschäftigt wie
lange geht das noch kann das noch gehen
muss das noch gehen wir wissen nicht wie
lange es noch gehen wird und wenn wir ja
sagen wie lange es noch gehen wird muss
man sagen es geht um einen krieg von dem
viele angenommen haben das nach 3 tagen
entschieden sein würde dass kiew erobert
sein würde russische truppen die gesamte
ukraine besitzen eine
marionettenregierung installiert wird
und die ukraine als eigenständiger staat
auch wird zu existieren das ist nicht
der fall bei allen grausamkeiten bei
allem leid das menschen in der ukraine
aber auch in russland in den letzten
sechs monaten widerfahren ist und dass
sie zu ertragen hatten muss man sagen
das ist eine überraschende und das ist
eine gute nachricht das ist dieses land
noch gibt eine souveräne schwer
verwundete ukraine die nach wie vor sich
wehrt dazu macht es ihrer einschätzung
und zu außenministerin hat heute in
einem interview gesagt wir würden
vermutlich auch nächsten sommer noch
schwere waffen liefern müssen das klingt
nicht nach einer schnellen klärung dass
sich sehr ähnlich dieser winter wird auf
jeden fall weiter hält ich krieg geführt
werden weil auch in diesem winter
natürlich die gaswaffe besonders
attraktiv scheint für putin sowohl was
die menschen in westeuropa betrifft aber
auch die menschen in der ukraine
und ich denke dass bisher überhaupt
keine bereitschaft gibt und weniger
bereitschaft als noch ende märz als man
über konkrete vorschläge sprach zu
verhandeln ist sommer und möglicher
weise wie frau woche auch gesagt hat
noch viele jahre leider eine
möglicherweise realistische perspektive
münstermann ist dass die perspektive im
politischen berlin noch viele jahre das
weiß ich nicht viele jahre wurde ich
fand ich heute etwas überraschend von
frau berbalk bisher sich auch kanzler
olaf scholz immer so eingelassen es wird
schwer vielleicht noch ein jahr also das
sagte er zu beginnen aber
ich glaube das thema was in berlin
gerade alle umtreibt ist das hat heute
auch im interview gesagt wie kann man
diesen begriff der kriegsmüdigkeit
entgegenwirken weil das ist er plötzlich
ein zynischer begriff also weil die
leute in der ukraine sind wahrscheinlich
auch kriegsmüde oder winter und haben
keine chance eine kriegsmüdigkeit zu
entwickeln weil ihr land angegriffen
wird und deswegen ist in berlin schon
der versuch diesen wir haben jetzt
andere themen gaspreise inflation und
klar aber kriegsmüde zu sein ist für
eine nation wie deutschland schon
schwierig gerade herr schulze sind nato
korrespondent in brüssel deshalb an sie
die frage wer hat was erreicht wo steht
dieser krieg militärisch
ich würde sagen für die russen
zufriedenstellend für die ukraine
schlecht ich finde die ukraine steht mit
dem rücken zur wand sie hat ungefähr 24
prozent des gebiets verloren aber man
muss wissen dass dort 80 prozent der
wertschöpfung erfolgen das ist der
industrie bereich der bass und es ist
vor allem die kornkammer um personen
runden im süden das heißt ohne diese
bezirke wäre die wenn es so bliebe wäre
die ukraine gar nicht lebensfähig 80
prozent der wertschöpfung
und die ukraine hat keine zeit die
russen haben zeit die können auf zeit
spielen und ich würde auch deswegen
unterstreichen was frau berbalk gesagt
hat das wird noch sehr lange dauern aber
die ukraine hat keine zeit und der
vorsitzende des präsidentenbüros görg
hat vor einigen tagen auch gesagt wir
müssen diesen krieg ende herbst beenden
dann wird es kalt und dann wird es nass
das wird aber nicht so sein aber die
ukraine hat als größte herausforderung
aus meiner sicht jetzt
dass sie 35 millionen traumatisierte
menschen durch den winter bringen müssen
und die russen
zerstören ganz gezielt infrastruktur für
wärme und energie das wird die große
herausforderung werden und ich glaube
anders als sie mit verlaub
dass es im winter keine
großen gefechte geben wird ich denke es
gibt er eine eine kampfpause mit
scharmützeln und
beide seiten versuchen sich zu
regenerieren es geht auf jeden fall noch
sehr lange weiter aber es wird nicht
verhandlungen und verhandlungsergebnis
geben im herbst das nicht also dass mein
team es kann sein könnte ich mir
durchaus vorstellen dass der konsens zu
sanktionen und waffenlieferung feld und
wenn die waffenlieferung noch weniger
werden als es jetzt ist dann hat die
ukraine ein problem weil sie ist 100
prozent auf uns angewiesen und wenn die
stimmung kippt im westen und die gefahr
ist groß in österreich sehen wir dass
gerade 40 prozent gegen sanktionen oder
zum teil gegen sanktionen in italien
werden wir eine neue rechtsregierung
wahrscheinlich bekommen die sehr putin
ist
ich bin nicht sicher ob es nicht unter
der führerschaft von herrn makro unter
herrn scholz dann dass man dann
versuchen wir zählen ski zu
verhandlungen zu drängen ich komme auf
ihren ersten punkt zurück
verhandlungen sind eine frage wird sich
später anschließen aber frau hat gesagt
die überraschend ist wahr dass die
ukraine diesen ersten sturm abwehren
konnte dass sie noch existiert sie
zeichnen jetzt ein bild von einem land
mit dem rücken an der wand das
eigentlich will ich sagen keine aber
wenig chancen hat die schlechteren
karten hat in diesem konflikt ist das
roboter ist das konsens an diesem tisch
bei münstermann hat so machen ich würde
sagen das widerspricht sich nicht denn
zum einen ist die position der ukraine
sehr viel besser als es noch im märz der
fall war
man rückt zwar nicht voran ist gelang
aber einige gebiete doch zurück zu
erobern und vor allem schafft man unruhe
mit gezielten taktischen schlägen auf
die krim auf munitionsdepots das ist
eben auch den waffenlieferungen zu
verdanken und das hat auswirkungen auf
den gegner das bleibt nicht ohne folgen
die kraft reicht aber nicht um
tatsächlich eine offensive im süden zu
starten und weil sie vor eben gerade
sagten im märz klagt das angebot für
verhandlungen auf den tisch das ist so
nicht richtig dieses angebot das auf dem
tisch lag war so hahn büchen die
forderung von russischen seite waren für
die ukrainische seite unerfüllbare
fanden sich punkte drauf ich eine den
artifiziellen der ukraine eine
militärische neutralität nachdem man
kurz davor ein land überfallen hat ich
glaube wenn es gelingt im süden
militärisch druck aufzubauen auf die
russische seite dann wird man an einen
punkt kommen wo die russische seite
tatsächlich irgendwann verhandeln muss
derzeit das muss man so sagen waren alle
verhandlungsoptionen die russische seite
vorgeschlagen hat ein witz also
unterscheiden sich das war ja ich rede
von den verhandlungen am 24 märz in der
türkei wo das letzte mal
regierungsdelegation live verhandelt
haben also nicht per zoom und wo die
ukrainische regierung seite ein
vorschlag gemacht hat reden nicht von
der russisch und zwar schwarz auf weiß
mit den sechs punkten wir verzichten auf
eine nato mitgliedschaft neutralität
keine fremden ausländisch
militärstützpunkte aber wir brauchen
verlässliche sicherheitsgarantien
bestimmter länder die dann ja auch
genannt wurden usa kanada polen
deutschland israel fünfter punkt war
über die beiden umstrittenen gebiete
dornbach deren status willich stellen
ski direkt mit putin verhandeln und der
letzte punkt war die creme freude dass
wir für 15 jahre offen und bis wir die
endgültig entscheiden das meinte ich
meinte nicht durch russische und seitdem
garantien waren ja nicht ausformuliert
ist
natürlich der punkt mit herrn putin
müsste man direkt verhandeln das fordert
das ist ja alles richtig
sie haben von das anderem geräte sie
haben von russischen positionen geräte
ich habe von einem ukrainischen geräte
und das sind wir seitdem weit weg von
auf beiden seiten das ist der punkt und
zur frau von einem schönen da bin ich in
der analyse also er
bei ihnen herrscht einmal glaube ich und
das ist unser dilemma dass diese
waffenlieferungen nicht das gewünschte
ziel erreichen werden wobei das ziel der
zum teil sehr unterschiedlich definiert
wird also das minimalziel wäre die
russischen truppen auf die linien hinter
dem 24 februar zurück zu drängen was ja
auch völkerrechtlich völlig in ordnung
wäre aber inzwischen formuliert ja auch
selensky auch per dekret sehr viel
weiter gehen dass wir haben gehört bis
hin zur rückeroberung der krim ich
glaube dass das eine illusion ist und
das ist ein dilemma mit dem man
irgendwie umgehen muss und die frage
beantwortet sich natürlich auch in der
differenzierung kurz mittel und
längerfristig in diesem winter wird es
so werden wie sie beschrieben haben sich
genauso
mittelfristig sind natürlich die
auswirkungen der sanktionen auf die
russische volkswirtschaft und die
fähigkeit russland auch diesen krieg
weiter zu führen und neue rüstungsgüter
zu rüsten zunehmend eingeschränkt aber
mittelfristig heiß hier eben nicht
übermorgen auch nicht im dezember heißt
frühestens ab mitte nächsten jahres ja
bei der die bereitschaft von putin sich
in irgendeiner weise einzulassen hat er
jetzt gerade noch mal mit der
ankündigungen 140000 mehr soldaten in
sein seine armee zu holen ad acta gelegt
also ich glaube putin ist derzeit kein
verhandlungspartner weder für den westen
noch für für sie lenski und ich finde
die die position von präsident seelands
die sehr interessant der ja zu beginn
des krieges in ein ganz klug ein
momentum genutzt hat für sein land zu
werben zu kämpfen er war in ich weiß
nicht allen internationalen gipfeln
dazugeschaltet er hat viele besucher
kommen in kiew aber und er hat jetzt zu
diesem halbjahres tag nochmal appelliert
aber an ihm wird es liegen schafft er es
seine bevölkerung durch einen winter zu
bekommen der sehr hart wird auch die
moral die die ukraine ja so unglaublich
gezeigt haben und die ja immer in allen
reden auch geschoren wird jetzt auch
wieder kanzler scholz präsident steuer
oder bundespräsident steinmeier
präsident biden also es geht immer um
diesen stolz und diese kraft der ukraine
aber wie lange kann das bleiben und ich
glaube dass an ihm ist auch liegen wird
zu sagen ich bin doch bereit jetzt einen
wie auch immer gearteten
waffenstillstand davor das muss man ihm
kommen ja also das also nicht ihren
versuch mal zu sortieren sie sind sich
einig dass wir im moment überhaupt nicht
in der situation sind wo verhandlungen
bevorstehen und die beteiligten dazu
bereit sind sie stimmen herrn schild zu
dass die ukraine vor einer ganz
schwierigen winter situation steht
mangels energie
mangels wärme mangels strom
möglicherweise und das habe ich jetzt
ihre äußerung entnommen im moment spielt
die waffen frage eine rolle aber die
frage dessen jahres moral haben sie es
genannt fraumünster man also wie viel
unterstützung hat man jeweils spielt
eine andere ich würde damit gerne
fortsetzen ich habe nur eine frage
bedanke mich erstmal bei allen die uns
live streams im gästebuch bei
tagesschau.de presseclub de folgen nicht
lese was sie so schreiben ich habe eine
frage die ich einfach ein schieben
möchte und bitte eine oder einen von
ihnen zu antworten viele die uns
schreiben
beschäftigt die situation am
atomkraftwerk labore haben die frage ist
wie bedrohlich ist das was kann das wird
daraus erwachsen der sitz ist bedrohlich
weil eben möglicherweise gar nicht aus
absicht oder hoffentlich nicht aus
absicht keiner seite trotzdem
unabsichtliche schlimmstes passieren
kann wenn also die stromversorgung
länger als das ja schon letzte woche
einmal kurzfristig geschehen ist
unterbrochen wird und damit die kühlung
dieses akw es ist eine katastrophe
größten ausmaßes vorstellbar die im
schlimmsten fall die auswirkung von
tschernobyl vom april selbst das steuer
der aber ist das was dir und aufhören
würde das ding zu beschießen wo man ja
ein bisschen widersprüchlich ist wer da
alles schief und deswegen die forderung
ja auch der internationalen atomenergie
organisation deren delegation ja immer
noch nicht reingelassen wurde und das
sind nun die russischen besatzer für
verantwortet um dieses lkw eine
möglichst große
entmilitarisierte zone zu schaffen in
der dann also weder russen noch
ukrainische militärs sind und die auch
so groß ist dass man sie nicht mit
zumindest mit kurzstreckenwaffen
beschließen kann also ohne grenzen dazu
sagen diese teile ihrer einschätzung das
große problem ist eben dass das
russische militär dort das belegen
videos der verifiziert worden sind ihre
technik untergebracht hat also sie haben
1 akw in einer phase ist okay
untergebracht und dadurch ist ist ein
zentrum der gerecht geworden und es
bleibt nur zu hoffen dass tatsächlich
die russische seite bereit ist ein zu
lenken dass das eben entsandte der
atomenergiebehörde endlich dort sich ein
bild vor ort machen kann ok danke ich
sie widersprechen mir nicht wenn ich
sage unberechenbar im moment und von
größter gefahr erst dann komme ich
zurück auf die frage von moral
die betrifft ja im moment natürlich die
ukraine deren moral wir glaube ich
bewundern alle sind erstaunt was der
präsident was die regierungen an
solidarität ausgelöst hat der russische
präsident will die armee um gut 100.000
soldaten vergrößern und hat die man
liest schwierigkeiten freiwillige dafür
zu finden
also insofern die frage wie sieht's mit
der mit der heimatfront in
anführungszeichen in russland aus und
dann würde ich sagen schauen wir mal auf
uns auf unsere psychologie dann sind wir
bei der frage unterstützung mit waffen
wie lange halten wir durch oder wollen
wir das gar nicht aber zunächst einmal
der blick auf die russische bin bin ich
bin kein russland expertin ich denke die
russen sind immer noch deutlich besser
aufgestellt als die ukraine weil die
erste garde der ukraine nach meinen
informationen ist weitgehend muss man
leider sagen dezimiert und mit der
ersten garde meine ich die
berufssoldaten und die leute die jetzt
nach drücken sind schlecht ausgebildet
sehr oft und sie haben auch nicht
genügend protektion also helme und so
weiter das ist ein großes problem da
steht glaube ich russland viel besser da
und so weit ich weiß will auch russland
im september ein neues programm mit zehn
milliarden dollar ankündigen für den
verteidigungsetat den zu erhöhen aber
die andere frage die sich schon noch
gestellt haben möchte ich doch gerne
beantworten oder in den blick nehmen
wir haben eben über verhandlungen so
verstellt sich dass er sie meinen die
frage was war lassen sie uns einmal ich
will einmal auf den blick auf moskau
verbote wurden sie da ergänzen und dann
warten wir den winter zu machen ich bin
noch nicht ganz so pessimistisch wie
herr schild die ankündigung dass man die
armee aufstocken will um fast 180
tausend soldaten zeigt ja dass ist der
russischen seite an ressourcen fehlt und
und die ressource mensch ist hier ein
ganz gewichtiger faktor
es gibt keine generalmobilmachung
diejenigen die sich haben verpflichten
lassen die mit prämien gelockt worden
sind waren eben keineswegs gut
ausgebildet auf der russischen seite und
es waren verträge die für ein halbes
jahr abgeschlossen worden sind oder für
ein jahr das sind sogenannte kontrakt
niki vertrag soldaten diese verträge
laufen jetzt aus die prämie die sie
gelockt haben gab es einmal in die frage
ist wer von ihnen ist bereit
weiterzumachen und ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass die bereitschaft da
nicht sehr ausgeprägt ist wenn wladimir
putin keine die mobilmachung verhängt
musste von irgendwoher diese 180000
bekommen ich vermute es geht darum in
den besetzten gebieten auf der ukraine
die männer quasi zu in kooperieren in
die russische armee aber es bleibt ein
problem das ist die bisher offiziell
zwar wenig dazu genauso ist es aber im
prinzip ändert das trotzdem nichts daran
dass die russische seite bald schon die
männer aus gehen und hier sehe ich eben
einen moment um das verhandlungen
ermöglichen könnte also man muss auch
sagen diese zahl die es auch genannt
worden ist die putin verkündet hat da
ist eben unklar geblieben ob das
vortrags soldaten sind bei uns würde man
seinen beruf sollte oder ob es
wehrpflichtige sind und bei bewerb
wichtigen ist nach zumindest der
bisherigen rechtslage in russland so
dass sie nicht außerhalb des eigenen
landes eingesetzt werden können dürfen
dass das macht möglicherweise noch
geändert werden ich glaube trotzdem
trotz dieser objektiven schwierigkeiten
dass die russische seite militärisch
nach wie vor sehr überlegen ist weil es
ist natürlich vergleichsweise für putin
einfacher ich nochmal soldaten zu
verheizen in diesem krieg und auch die
opferzahlen zum teil der im heimischen
bevölkerung zu verschweigen dass gesagt
die kämpfen weiterhin an der front
obwohl sie längst tote als ist das für
viele ist und wenn wir uns die waffen
angucken haben wir nach wie vor eine
große überlegenheit in der luftwaffe
sowieso aber auch bei der zahl der
artilleriegeschütze der reichweite der
artilleriegeschütze und daher ist ein
bisschen meine skepsis ob man das mit
waffenlieferung jemals aber da kommen
wir gleich zu ich glaube nur einen
letzten punkt nach putin hat in diesem
krieg bisher die ich sag mal die
eskalation stream - und die liegt nach
wie vor noch bei ihm und putin russland
hat nach meiner analyse auch glaube ich
die größere
durchhaltefähigkeit noch jedenfalls weil
er eben an der eigenen bevölkerung mehr
zumuten kann als der westen oder auch
als lenski und wenn man auf die
wirtschaftssanktionen gucke ich sag mal
wenn eine in einem westlichen demokratie
dass die wirtschaft schon 0,5 prozent
zurückgeht hat die politik ein problem
wenn es in russland um sechs prozent
zurückgeht ist das noch kein problem das
meine ich mit größerer durchhalten das
auto macht nicht immer eine eskalation
dominanz also ich glaube am ende
es ist sehr sehr schwierig gegen die die
atommacht russland tatsächlich einen
krieg zu gewinnen wie auch immer man das
definiert sie haben sie haben finde ich
sehr differenziert jetzt das bild
gezeichnet der beiden kriegsparteien
am ende ist es in fast allen punkten
eine russische dominanz eine russische
überlegenheit und die wird ja zu einem
guten teil ausgeglichen durch
waffenlieferungen der nato des westens
kam durch deutschen waffenlieferungen
seit den ersten wochen dieses krieges
also kommen wir zu der frage
wie viele waffen will kann soll der
westen liefern herschels stoltenberg der
nato-generalsekretär hat gesagt die
ukraine muss sich durchsetzen sie wird
sich durchsetzen und das ist der satz
nachdem ich sie fragen will die nato
wird sie so lange unterstützen wie nötig
was bedeutet das für unterstützung
bekommt die ukraine das ist seine
hoffnung ich hatte diese woche die
gelegenheit ihn zu interviewen und da
hat er ganz deutlich gesagt in diesem
interview für die welt und die welt am
sonntag wir müssen deutlich mehr tun und
zwar sehr schnell
und sehr viel mehr und er hat dabei auch
deutschland in den blick genommen und
auf die besondere verantwortung
deutschlands hingewiesen als größte
volkswirtschaft mehr kann er nicht tun
als nato-generalsekretär aber der westen
steht jetzt vor der frage
erst einmal
was wollen wir eigentlich erreichen mit
unserem engagement in der ukraine
oder wollen wir den fehler begehen den
wir bei afghanistan begangen haben wo
jeder eine andere erwartung hatte an
diese an dieser operation
wollen wir erreichen dass putin weggeht
sowie herr beiden gesagt hat wollen wir
erreichen dass die russen nicht mehr in
der lage sind einen ähnlichen angriff in
den nächsten jahren auszuführen wie
verteidigungsminister ostern gesagt hat
oder wollen wir nur erreichen die unser
bundeskanzler gesagt hat dass putin
nicht siegen darf was immer das auch
heißt er hat nicht einmal gesagt die
ukraine muss gewinne hat gesagt putin
darf nicht siegen wollen wir also
schnelle verhandlungen
und wenn der westen sich jetzt nicht
entscheidet massiv mehr waffen zu
liefern dann wird die ukraine diesen
krieg verlieren nicht alle münstermann
verbot daher zu macht werden
interessant dass also urlaubs hat ja
jetzt gerade auf dem grill gipfel dabei
selbst in kanada aber nochmal weitere
hilfe angekündigt für die ukraine
weitere waffensysteme
interessanterweise hat sich die
regierung sehr lange sehr schwer getan
mit der lieferung schwerer waffen da war
die unterstützung in der bevölkerung
dafür sehr hoch und jetzt erleben wir
ein bisschen dass die unterstützung laut
umfragen da deutlich zurückgeht
stichwort kriegsmüdigkeit oder
gewöhnungseffekte und jetzt hat man das
gefühl es wobei man sagen muss es gibt
immer noch klar eine mehrheitliche
unterstützung
also ist nicht mehr sooo überwältigend
wie sie mal war und
was ich höre in berlin ist schon wenn
man mit militärs in berlin spricht dass
die sagen
gebt befürchten so einen ausverkauf von
unseren dingen für die wir für unseren
schutz einsetzen könnten also ich glaube
die da geht es in der bundesregierung
zwischen verteidigungsministerium
außenministerium frau berbalk wirkt sehr
vehement für die lieferung schwerer
waffen und kanzleramt hin und her und
ich sehe die bereitschaft weitere waffen
stichwort marder oder so zu liefern
derzeit nicht in der bundesregierung der
frau brutal ich finde herr schild hat
die kernfrage formuliert was ist
eigentlich das ziel so viel zu liefern
wie möglich oder so viel wie nötig und
wofür vor allem schneller zu handeln
alle lieferungen die kam kam eigentlich
immer verzögert und während wir
debattieren was soll man liefern und
wann wird kriegsgerät an der front
zerstört das heißt das was man vor drei
monaten beschlossen hat ist drei vier
monaten später schon wieder viel zu
wenig aber ein punkt karte gerade die
absurd dass vor 12 jahren noch geklungen
hätte würde bei welcher reden und da so
rein wie fern kriegsgerät an die front
wo es zerstört wird damit wir neues liga
an ein punkt der
hier noch nicht glaube ich so zu betonen
oder ist was steht auf dem spiel die
ukraine hat deshalb ein solches
interesse an solche bereitschaft zu
kämpfen weil ihre existenz auf dem spiel
steht es ist dieser krieg kann von der
russischen seite jederzeit beendet
werden in der theorie bei der ukraine
gibt es keinen plan b wladimir putin hat
wieder und wieder gesagt dass er die
ukraine nicht als einen eigenständigen
staat andere können wir haben gesehen
dass russische soldaten in den vororten
von kiew an anderen orten alles was die
ukrainische staatlichkeit konstituiert
zerstört haben es wurde bezieht nach
männern gesucht die im donbass gekämpft
oder die in der polizei sind und simon
sind getötet worden es gibt also
sozusagen keine alternative das ist die
ukrainische position und ich habe in der
vergangenen woche die eltern eines sehr
bekannten ukrainischen aktivisten
getroffen maximovitsch heißt dieser mann
einen link der sich immer für
geflüchtete eingesetzt hatten ein
pazifist
ein antimilitarist der sich im märz
freiwilligen die für die armee gemeldet
hat und im juni in kriegsgefangenschaft
geraten ist und selbst die eltern die
wissen dass ihr sohn in den händen des
feindes ist die nicht wissen wie es ihm
geht ob er gefoltert worden ist ob er
überhaupt am leben ist sagen wir
brauchen waffen weil wir davon überzeugt
sind dass wir nur so diesen krieg
beenden kann dazu macht roboter hat
jetzt meine frage
ob dem umweg beantwortet ich habe es so
verstanden dass sie gesagt hat es geht
um das prinzip der selbstbestimmung
eines volkes um das prinzip staatlicher
souveränität deshalb kann sie noch mal
die frage was ist das ziel des bestens
was ist unser deutsches ziel es ist
genauso unklar wie der kollege sitzt es
eben beschrieben hat sie haben die
spannbreite von den zitierten äußerungen
aus washington aber auch von frau war
auf der einen seite bis hin zu den aus
italien von der regierung und auch vom
vatikan gekommenen
vorschlägen die er im kern dasselbe sind
wie das von 24 märz bus noch regelungen
dafür wie das dann auch überwacht und
durchgesetzt werden kann und mit einer
solchen vielstimmigen chor lässt sich
natürlich irgendwo auch politischer
eindruck machen also ich finde meinte
doch noch mal die perspektive etwas
aufmachen wenn ich von der analyse
ausgehe und das hat mir zumindest alle
militärischen experten die keine eigene
politische agenda haben dass die
russisch überlegenheit so hoch ist dass
sich das auch mit noch so vielen
waffenlieferungen nicht ausgleichen ist
längst selbst nicht hin zu dem punkt
eines sogenannten militärischen
erschöpfungs pass was dann zumindest zu
einem waffenstillstand wird wenn das die
analyse ist dann ist schon die frage was
wäre die alternative
und da muss ich schon sagen der muss man
sich zumindest darüber nachdenken was
sind die übergeordneten ziele und da ein
übergeordnetes ziel ist sicher von für
uns alle die eskalation hin zu einer
atomaren
auseinandersetzung zu verhindern
inklusive der es nicht gewollten
katastrophe über die wir eben schon
gesprochen haben und das zweite wäre
also ich bin sicher wenn china
die chinesische führung zu dem ergebnis
kommen dass funktionierende lieferketten
weiterhin bestehender absatzmärkte usa
und europa wichtiger sind als die
partnerschaft mit dem juniorpartner
russland hätte die chinesische regierung
die instrumente in der hand und gut hin
zu einem waffenstillstand zu bringen und
der westen wenn er denn eine gemeinsame
position hätte unter führung der usa
hätte das auch und jetzt kommt aber
darauf an worüber wir reden das wird
dann immer so getan als wolle damit man
damit die souveränität und die statische
integrität der der so der ukraine auf
ewig beschneiden nein ich kann nur sagen
was immer möglicherweise an einem
verhandlungstisch zunächst mal
vereinbart wird kann und darf nicht die
endgültige völkerrechtliche anerkennung
dann dieses ergebnis oder suche noch mal
wissen
sondern es wird ein schmutziger deal
sein wenn es überhaupt ein baby ist
völlig klar aber der ist nicht auf dauer
in stein gemeißelt dass sich doch noch
gar nicht angezeigt und günstiger machen
dem dilemma heraus was sie auch
beschrieben ich gebe den ball jetzt
anfragen münstermann auch sie haben
meine frage was ist das ziel ein
bisschen anders beantwortet
zugespitzt haben sie mir gesagt dass sie
für das wichtigste ziel hielten nämlich
die vermeidung eines atomkriegs so und
eine eskalation will merkel dann auch
deshalb ich komme die frage gerade um
also ihre meinungen und einschätzungen
passen müsste denn das ziel westlichen
deutschen handelns sein das ist glaube
ich zweigeteilt zum einen ist das die
aufrechterhaltung eines einer demokratie
in der ukraine eines demokratischen
staates die wir das sind unsere werte
die dort auf dem spiel stehen also da
bin ich ganz bei frau uta und dafür
kämpft dieses land weil das gerne sich
zum westen zur nato wie auch immer
zugehörig fühlen möchte ich finde die eu
ist ja auch einen schritt auf uns
zugegangen und hat gesagt ihr kommt auf
jeden fall auf unserer seite
andererseits und ich glaube dass es das
was auch den den konflikt des westens
ganz gut beschreibt ist jetzt gerade
urlaub scholz in magdeburg mit bürgern
zusammen getroffen die ihn sehr besorgt
gefragt haben wohin führt das alles und
dann betont der kanzler der vorher bei
den ukrainischen soldaten die in
ausbildung in deutschland sind war und
ihnen unterstützung zugesagt hat sagt am
selben abend nun wir müssen immer
aufpassen dass unsere waffen sozusagen
nicht angriffswaffen für ein angriff auf
die auf russland werden können und da
ist er in der linie sieht er sich mit
präsident biden und mit in anderen
europäischen staaten nehmen kann und ich
glaube das beschreibt den vier konflikt
sehr genau darf ichs dhabis zugespitzt
formulieren herschels ist das
praktizierte ziel des westens die
ukraine nicht verlieren zu lassen aber
sie auch russland nicht so provozieren
zu lassen das ist unberechenbar wird ich
glaube es gibt da keine klare richtung
eine klare richtschnur der westen ist
sich darüber nicht im klaren was polen
will ist was anderes als deutschland
will was die amerikaner wollen ist etwas
anderes als italien will das ist ein
großes problem dabei
aber ich glaube unser gemeinsames ziel
des westens der freien gesellschaften
muss es sein dass sich dieser brutale
krieg für putin nicht auszahlt und dass
er nicht gewinnt und mit gewinnen meine
ich dass er am ende mehr land in der der
ukraine besitzt als er jetzt schon
vorher kontrolliert hat dass er also
keine land gewinne macht und sein ziel
ist nicht die ganze ukraine zu erobern
das glaube ich nicht weil das würde
einen partisanenkrieg hervorrufen den er
nicht kontrollieren kann er will den
süden abschneiden er will die ukraine
vom
schwarzen und asowschen meer abschneiden
dann kann sie nicht mehr exportieren und
das meint frau berbalk auch dann müssten
wir nämlich die ukraine eigentlich für
immer
finanzieren sie ist dann gar nicht mehr
wirtschaftlich lebensfähig und
und lassen sie mich das noch sagen
dürfen ich verstehe darum nicht das
österreichische außenminister
verteidigungsministerium sagt es werden
nur 10 bis 15 prozent der waffen
geliefert wie eigentlich benötigt würden
ich verstehe nicht warum so wenig
geliefert wird und ich verstehe vor
allem nicht warum bundeskanzler scholz
so zaubert mit diesem zickzackkurs hin
und her man erkennt überhaupt keine
strategie punktuell wird mal wieder was
versprochen morgen hält er eine rede in
prag wird er wahrscheinlich wieder etwas
versprechen aber man sieht keine
strategie es gibt auch keine verbindung
zwischen instandsetzung lieferung und
ausbildung das ist alles so
tröpfchenweise fr butter ist dran ich
versuche nur weil
ja weil ich ein bisschen klarheit
schaffen will also ein wichtiger satz
den sie gesagt haben ist der besten hat
kein einheitliches ziel hat schumacher
hat genug dass verschiedene länder
einfach verschiedene perspektiven haben
das ist ja auch nachvollziehbar und sie
beide haben beschrieben wie
widersprüchlich interpretierbar die
jeweiligen äußerungen des bundeskanzlers
in kabul ich würde widersprechen dass
das lade mir putin den süden der ukraine
geht es geht ihnen nimmt sich das was er
kriegt deshalb gab es ja den versuch
kiew einzunehmen der ist gescheitert und
dann hat man sich auf den süden
verlagert sobald es dort die russische
seite das signal bekommt das sie
weitergehen könnte würde sie weitergehen
deshalb ist glaube ich nicht wäre ein
unendlicher partizan aber all das es gab
ja diese operation in den ersten tagen
wo man in einer stadt kostüme heißt wo
ein flughafen ist einheiten entsandt hat
die kef einigen sollten und da hat sich
die russische seite spektakulär
verspekuliert
aber insofern das was möglich ist wird
die russische seite versuchen andere
unterschiedliche einschätzungen das ist
ja auch in ordnung aber hat zu nehmen
was was will der westen was mich
manchmal so ein bisschen befremdet bei
den diskussionen über die ukraine ist
dass sie sehr schnell weg davon sind was
die ukraine eigentlich will und was sie
eigentlich braucht und die ukrainische
seite formuliert eigentlich sehr sind
deutlich und sehr klar was sie benötigt
und bevor es um irgendwelche ziele
anderer länder geht um
zukunftsperspektiven sollte man doch der
ukrainischen seite zu hören
und das ernst nehmen könnte es sein frau
münstermann das im laufe dieses winter
ist die deutsche haltung klar wird
nämlich
alles was den krieg schnell beendet und
wieder gas in die leitungen bringt ist
deutsche position ich glaube das wird
bleibt weiter immer mehr verwässert denn
tatsächlich sieht sicher die deutsche
regierung das haben wir erleben wir ja
auch gerade auch schon
einem desaströsen herbst voraus also
sprich gas das nicht fließt führt ja in
der bundesregierung dazu dass wir
instrumente einsetzen wollen die nicht
klar kommunizieren stichwort gas umlage
dann wieder weiter verbessern und
gleichzeitig steigt schon nicht der
druck von der straße noch sehen wir
keine demonstration aber der unbill der
bevölkerung und der richtet sich dann
auch gegen die frage geben dass freund
zu beginnen mit dem herren auf dem markt
glaube ich ganz gut eingefangen um krieg
und sanktionen aber jetzt haben wir ja
hier
massive probleme also die eigentlich ist
jetzt eine regierung gefragt die
kommunikativ bestes leistet nämlich eben
klar macht warum man die ukraine
unterstützt und warum das nötig ist und
was es dafür braucht und was man dann
auch auf deutscher seite für opfer in
kauf nimmt also mit putin sind wir alle
auch in einem gas-krieg offensichtlich
verfeuert er gas neben der pipeline
bedeutet es gibt es im überfluss er
leitet nicht durch um etwas zu erreichen
und das sind krieg ganz ohne opfer geht
haben wir jetzt schlimm gelernt ist ist
klar und ich deswegen glaube ich nicht
dass die bundesregierung im laufe dieses
winters klarer sich zur ukraine und den
waffenlieferungen bekennen wird als wir
das jetzt gerade so das scheibchenweise
erleben zu also ich würde gerne eine
frage noch mal schön formen schon einmal
vor in zitiert als gemeinsame linie so
nämlich auf wahl zwischen allen nach
ausschalten auch der beiden
administration keine waffen zu liefern
mit den
angriffs akte auf russisches territorium
möglich wären das hatte ich nie
verstanden das macht sich doch nicht an
reichweitentest wenn ich mit einem 40
kilometer reichweite fähigen
artilleriegeschütze 20 kilometer von der
russischen grenze stehe kann ich im
russischen tor machen schießen da
brauche ich dann nicht als sie recht
aber das argument nation die man sich
gar nicht panzer kampfpanzer warum lief
das habe ich nie für eine klare linie
weder in bonn noch in berlin schuld
ein zweiter punkt aber ist zielt auf den
punkt und ihre freiheit also die frage
was ist ein grad für unterstützung hier
gibt in der deutschen bevölkerung das
muss kann ich es nur für waffen liefern
sie auch für das durchhalten der
sanktionen hängt natürlich sehr davon ab
ob es dieser regierung gelingt die
finanziellen lasten die das ganze für
uns alles bedeutet gerecht zu verteilen
wenn das nicht gelingt und das sieht im
moment leider so aus dass umlage keine
über gewinn steuer sondern den
energiekonzernen die dicke gewinne
gemacht haben auch noch geld in raten
schweiz dann wird es hier protest zu
geben und dann fertig werden die
proteste auch von ganz rechts kommen und
von all denen die sehr viel mehr als
ziel im auge haben als nur diesen
konflikt und das ist aber nur für handys
politisch entschieden werden im moment
sind es ganz rechts und ganz ganz links
über proteste treten die wir
nicht haben ich will aus diesen letzten
beiden runden noch mal sagen ob es dem
kapitän geht sie haben genannt atomkrieg
formaten wird jeder zustimmen wir haben
über die souveränität das prinzip der
selbstbestimmung von völkern gesprochen
es ist ja auch kein banales ziel dass
menschen nicht in einer krise frieren
sich sorgen ihre existenz machen müssen
ich glaube all diese dinge abzuwägen ist
in der tat auch schwer wir sind sag mal
nah dran an einer schlussrunde und
deshalb will ich sie zum schluss gebe
als einfach nochmal prognostisch um
einen blick nach vorne bitten der winter
ist vorbei wir sind irgendwann in
anderthalb jahren dieses krieges oder
ein anderthalb ssten jahr irgendwann im
nächsten frühjahr oder sommer herrscht
wo stehen wir dann ich glaube erst mal
wird die ukraine
es nicht schaffen den don was zu halten
ich glaube da werden die russischen
truppen einen erfolg erzielen
wahrscheinlich noch vor dem herbst auf
der anderen seite wird die
gegenoffensive die seit mai angekündigte
gegenoffensive der ukraine im süden
nicht klappen und damit wird man in den
winter gehen und dann wird es eine
neuaufstellung sozusagen am anfang oder
im kommenden frühjahr geben
und wenn wir dann immer noch bei dieser
schlechten ausrüstung durch westliche
waffen sind wird die ukraine untergehen
da bin ich ganz sicher das ist ihre
prognose herz nach wäre ihre prognose
dass verhandelt wird morgen ist heute
ein jahr also zunächst mal möchte
ausdrücklich festhalten dass
übergeordnete ziel keiner eskalation
eines krieges mit der nato gar mit
atomwaffen ist nicht konträr zu dem ziel
die souveränität der ukraine in ihrem
bisher in grenzen und die schließt
ausdrücklich ein die krim
aufrecht zu erhalten bzw wieder dahin zu
kommen also das was ich nicht gegen das
nicht ausspielen die frage ist wie kommt
man dahin und da wird die frau bot doch
an einem punkt widersprechen nicht alles
was herr selensky an forderungen
aufstellt müssen wir uns eins zu eins
übernehmen wenn er jetzt seit einigen
tagen gesagt die krim militärisch zurück
erobern zu wollen
würde ich mir doch wünschen dass aus
hessischen regierung ihm da auch gesagt
wird das ist sicher das der falsche weg
und dafür das können wir nicht
unterstützt also meine prognose ist
möglicherweise ähnlich wie sie das
gesagt haben was den winter bis zum
frühjahr betrifft aber meine befürchtung
ist es eben dass es da
zwischenzeit zu einer katastrophe kommen
könnte die die dinge völlig wendet also
atomkraft ja frau minister man ja ich
möchte vielleicht keine befürchtung
sondern eine hoffnung formulieren ich
glaube das thema verhandlungen
vielleicht sehr nötig wäre dass der
westen sich über ein ziel klar wird und
dann die bisherigen verhandlungsbeginn
ausgerechnet der türkei zwar
nato-mitglied aber sonst ja auch
belastet unterstützt das man also eine
diplomatische lösung immer in einer
beziehung mit der ukraine sucht die dann
vielleicht
sprich g20 bali möglicherweise gibt es
dort ein aufeinandertreffen mit putin
mit verschiedenen
internationalen staatenlenker ist dass
ihre hoffnung dass ihre probleme ja
meine prognose ist dass das nicht von 17
sollte haben sie mich jetzt getroffen
ich glaube dass einfach ein ja dieses
kräftemessen 1 1 tanzte einfach weiter
andauern wird und ganz ganz viele
menschen dabei dabei sterben werden und
das kann nicht unser interesse sein
verbote vielleicht ein szenario von dem
ich hoffe dass es eintritt und das sich
aber auch nicht für komplett
unwahrscheinlich halte
der westen liefert waffen an die ukraine
der druck auf die russische seite wird
erhöht das funktioniert so lange es kann
den generalmobilmachung im ausland geben
wird die rhetorik von hänsel enz die
garde ich kam zurück zu holen ist auch
vor dem hintergrund zu sehen dass man
rhetorisch aufrüstet und an einen
verhandlungstisch wieder abzurüsten und
im frühjahr wird die russische seite
endlich wahrhaftig verhandeln denn alles
was sie besser gesehen haben war man
muss es zusagen von der russischen seite
ein schmierentheater es sind wirklich
komplett unbetreut unbedeutende person
ins tal die diese verhandlung führen das
muss auf eine ebene höher gehen oder
zwei oder drei und am besten mit
wladimir putin direkt verhandeln wenn
den druck hoch genug ist dann könnte das
im frühjahr klappen bedanke mich sehr
herzlich
ja es ist schwierig und auch nicht sehr
fröhlich in die zukunft zu gucken aber
ich glaube es ist wichtig die
verschiedenen perspektiven zu verstehen
dabei haben sie alle sehr geholfen
vielen herzlichen dank wenn sie weiter
dabei sein wollen dann hier bei phoenix
und wdr 5 im radio presseclub
nachgefragt sonst in der heidi jetzt das
europamagazin danke dass sie dabei sind
schüsse und schönen sonntag aus köln
lassen bis gut gehen
[Musik]
und willkommen zurück presseclub
nachgefragt im radio bei wdr 5 im
fernsehen bei phoenix und wir beginnen
in stuttgart markus hummel hat uns
angerufen kommen im presseclub sie haben
das wort herum ja guten tag hier zwei
pleiten und zwar einmal warum werden die
leopard nicht geliefert die industriell
diese doch vor und könnte jederzeit li
vom punkt 2 welchen sinn machen die
kenntnis von den vielen strapazen durch
die hohen energiekosten
stichwort prävention
wenn ich gleichzeitig militärisch 100
prozent geliefert wird also ich meine
damit beispiel vokale will und braucht
muss geliefert werden es macht gar
keinen hehl
danke das ist eine klare frage der traut
sich also man die zweite schließt im
grunde die erste ein wert solcher eine
antwort zu
haben sich nicht verstellen so würden
sie noch mal eben so ok also herum
gefragt warum
wird nicht konsequent geliefert warum
dort der leonard der leopard 1 panzer
nicht geliefert und das macht es für
einen sinn dass wir unsere wirtschaft
riskieren und unsere versorgung
riskieren wenn wir nicht konsequent
alles tun damit mit waffen die ukraine
den krieg gewinnen kann so herr hummel
hab ich sie lagern
also ich kann dazu nur sagen ich habe
die ganzen argumentationen auf die
unterscheidung zwischen so in einem
leichten und so genannten schweren
waffen sogenannten nur zur verteidigung
fähig und anderem mit denen man offensiv
fähig sein kann nie verstanden auch
lange vor dem konflikt nicht auch in
dieser debatte ich habe zwei das
argument was man vorher noch mal zitiert
halt auch bis heute nicht verstanden als
sie die verteilungs ministerin zitiert
haben damit dass wir bald nichts mehr
haben was wir abgeben können weil wir es
für eigene landesverteidigung brauchen
an welche szenarien ist da eigentlich
gedacht den nächsten jahren wer uns
angreifen könnte also von daher sehe ich
auch kein kohärentes argument dafür
nicht mehr waffen zu liefern bei aller
skepsis die ich gegenüber diesem ansatz
sicher beschrieben hat er danke ich kann
alles gut auf dem ohr hören aber ich
bitte sie vielleicht die ein spieler aus
dem studio ein bisschen lauter zu machen
wir sind in münchen simkarten guten tag
hat schon guten tag
meine frage lautet
im letzten eines international berichtet
auch auf der ukrainischen seite zu
kriegsverbrechen die waffen die sie
liefern werden den kranken was an den
schulen versteckt hinter zivilisten
frauen kindern wie können wir
verantworten in dieser situation dennoch
waffen zu liefern den blick verdecken
stattfinden dann kann ich ja danke für
ihre klare frage nicht zu dem bericht
selbst der hoch umstritten ist die
amnesty international ai sektion in der
ukraine selbst war nicht einverstanden
in welcher form der bericht
veröffentlicht worden ist und ist
zurückgetreten
sie haben die frauen die kinder
angesprochen soweit mir bekannt es geht
es nicht darum dass sie in
krankenhäusern oder kindergärten waren
als diese in nutzung waren sondern dass
sie einen diese diese orte benutzt haben
als diese städte von der russischen
seite angegriffen worden sind das ist
natürlich ein großer unterschied
insofern bei dem amnesty international
bericht ist von vielen seiten auch von
experten für für kriegsrecht und
kriegsverbrechen sehr kritisiert wurden
nichtsdestotrotz muss ich sagen das
verbrechen auf beiden seiten natürlich
aufs schärfste zu verurteilen sind und
die ukraine diese auch untersuchen muss
ich glaube der bericht ist dafür
sozusagen nicht ja nicht der beweis den
man die man dem mann in diesem fall
nachgehen muss aber man sollte auf jeden
fall hier wachsam bleiben ich
will eigentlich versprecher immer dass
wir hier keine diskussion machen über
einzelne fragen aber ich will das was
sie vielleicht hat schon im hinterkopf
haben bei anders formulieren wie fair
sind wir in unserer berichterstattung
mit den kriegsparteien die uns
naturgemäß unterschiedlich nahestehen
oder anders gefragt also neigen wir dazu
bei der ukraine
verbrecherischer oder völker
rechtswidriges vorgehen kriegs
rechtswidriges vorgehen nicht sehen zu
wollen
krieg stirbt immer die wahrheit und zwar
auf beiden seiten aber natürlich sind
wir ich glaube da sind wir uns auch hier
am tisch und ohnehin alle einig die
ukraine wurde angegriffen wollte keinen
krieg beginnen das ist ein angriffskrieg
und wir unterstützen die ukraine
deswegen ist natürlich unsere sichtweise
in teilen gefärbt und ich finde auch
völlig zu recht aber es gibt hier einen
großen unterschied kriegsverbrechen
geschehen gehabt ukrainischen seite und
sie sind von journalisten journalisten
auch
beschrieben worden aber ich denke da zum
beispiel an der sammlung von russischen
soldaten das war eine linie präsenten
der unterschied ist dass es sich in bei
der ukrainische seite um punktuelle
verbrechen geht handelt die schlimm
genug sind während dieser form von
kriegsverbrechen bei der russischen
seite ein teil der kriegstaktik zu sein
scheint also ich würde auch gerne
aussagen völlig unabhängig davon ob der
bericht korrekte ist halt den bericht
für korrekt aber es wird ich verstehe
auch manchmal nicht warum die frage
gestellt wird in solchen diskussionen
russland ist der aggressor da gibt es
überhaupt keine frage und der krieg
selber ist bereits ein schweres
verbrechen und die in diesem krieg
begangenen kriegsverbrechen verbrechen
gegen die menschheit möglicherweise
sogar völkermord das wird noch geklärt
sind auf russischer seite und wenn dann
ein verteilt sich verteidigen das land
möglicherweise waffen in zivile gebäude
stellt was nach dem humanitären
völkerrecht dem sogenannten
kriegsvölkerrecht nicht erlaubt ist ist
das ein verstoß gegen das humanitäre
völkerrecht aber sollte nicht dazu
führen dass man auf eine ebene zu heben
und ist auch kein argument dafür keine
waffen mehr zu liefern wenn man der
überzeugung ist waffen sind das richtige
instrument danke ich glaube der
austausch sei wichtig hat schon danke
dass sie uns in diese richtung geführt
haben muss nach münchen
und gladbeck im ruhrgebiet ist die
nächste station gabriele martin guten
tag frau martin guten körper ein film
crews in die runde
das ist meine hände auftritt in den
weiteren westen polens tschechoslowakei
die gold-mission wellen oder vielleicht
noch deutschland
das ist eine absolut berechtigte frage
und gerade im baltikum und im osten wird
diese gefahr auch gesehen und deswegen
ist es ebenso wichtig dass wir die
ukraine mit ausreichend waffen beliefern
damit nicht der eindruck entsteht für
putin ich brauche nur militärische
mittel einzusetzen und das wird belohnt
weil wenn er einmal diese erfahrung
macht dann wird er das bei anderen
ländern möglicherweise nato staaten auch
versuchen denken sie zum beispiel ich
sehe zum beispiel sehr gefährdet
moldawien transnistrien
sehr gefährdet also wir müssen alles tun
damit bei russland sich nicht der
eindruck festsetzen
einsatz brutaler krieg zahlt sich aus
und deswegen ist das so wichtig ist eine
absolut irre ihre ihre sorge danke schön
dramatisch
ich habe auch
alles gute ich gehe mal hier in unseren
stream auf twitter fragt fabian
inwieweit verhindert der linke
parteiflügel der spd die notwendige
zeitenwende in bezug auf die lieferung
der waffensysteme bei münstermann ich
glaube dass dem linken parteiflügel der
spd da zu viel
einfluss
zugeschrieben wird also ja es gibt eine
gewisse russland freundlichkeit der
partei die gab es immer die hat sich
durch die neue führung durch den kanzler
glaube ich das wurde erkannt sie haben
jetzt das problem wie geht man mit
altkanzler gerhard schröder um da wird
eine menge versucht aber die spd-linke
die jetzt gerade auch wieder einen top 3
politiker ein brief formuliert haben
indem man eben auch sagte wir müssen mit
putin verhandeln das halte ich für
übertrieben die zuschreibung in chemnitz
in sachsen es werner karlin am telefon
guten tag
ich
freue mich dass ich durchgekommen zu ihm
ich habe heute früh eine
mitteilung im mdr gehört dass unser
ministerpräsident der eigentlichen
fakten sehr geachtet ist wohl eher als
unerwünschte person
in der ukraine erklärt das macht uns
alle ich habe heute schon mit mehreren
telefonieren wir geben uns große mühe in
chemnitz jahren gerade für sie 200
polnischen schüler einen makel neue
schule hier können die jungen leute in
betrieb nehmen und jetzt können wir so
eine meldung
zu unerwünscht bezeichnet dann finden
wir in wachsender nicht gut ja danke
dass sie das auf den tisch bringen hat
die tagesschau opfer hin gemeldet er
hatte diese woche in einer talkshow
friedensverhandlungen gefordert und hat
auch sonst
positionen formuliert weil die nicht in
der mitte der cdu liegen ja abwehr will
das von also ich halte es für völlig
unakzeptabel und ich wünsche mir dass
die bundesregierung beschlossen und auch
die cdu hier
protestiert auch wenn es nur herr melnik
ist der noch botschafter in berlin das
formuliert hat aber das liegt ja leider
in einer linie des dekrets des
kulturministeriums vor einigen wochen wo
bestimmte personen aus deutschland die
auch andere positionen öffentlich
formuliert haben auf eine verräter liste
gesetzt worden mit dem ergebnis dass
diese menschen hier bei uns ich nenne
beispielsweise den professor weg zu
hause inzwischen bedroht werden mit
ihrer familie und unter schutz gestellt
werden ist das ist völlig unakzeptabel
und ich finde die bundesregierung sollte
das nicht nur hinter verschlossenen
türen diplomatischen aller deutlichkeit
nach er wirkt aber man muss aber sagen
dass es keine regierungspolitik der
ukraine sondern herr wenig hatte in der
vergangenheit eine einladung an herrn
kretschmer ausgesprochen in die ukraine
zu kommen denn wir wissen ja dass der
kretschmann
zuletzt im kreml war und positionen
vertritt die der ukrainischen seite
inakzeptabel erscheint gut aber die
erste weisse
ihn ein dass er in die ukraine kommen
sich selbst ein bild macht und ich habe
es so verstanden dass diese einladung
wieder zurückgezogen worden aber ganz
ehrlich ich glaube man kann den
höhere auch beruhigen das sind die
letzten zuckungen wenn ich mal so etwas
despektierlich formulieren darf eines
botschafters der abgerufen wurde der
hierfür große wellen gesorgt hat aber
der jetzt dessen zeit in deutschland im
oktober abläuft und der sich jetzt auf
twitter nochmal bemüßigt sah das
sozusagen mit herrn kretschmann zu
diskutieren ich glaube dass dem darf man
gar nicht so viel bedeutung sollte der
bundeskanzler ein klares wort sprechen
wenn wir haben ja auch schon mal die
situation gehabt dass unser
bundespräsident
nicht willkommen war es schon der
eindruck entstanden dass ein bisserl
davon abhängt wo man politisch steht und
was man gerade gesungen aber der
präsident zwar ausgeladen pardon von
also das ging in seelands die kreise das
war die höchste politische führung der
ukraine
das war durchaus ein problem hier aber
dass es unklug empfunden aber herr may
liegt er jetzt auf twitter eine
nicht öffentliche einladungen oder eine
einladung wieder zurücknimmt ich glaube
kalina darf ihnen noch etwas dazu sagen
der tag für ihn dank für ihre
meinungen
vermeldet hat ja nun schon wirklich sehr
vieles gesagt das können wir auch
verstehen aber das haben wir heute
jedenfalls im mdr war eine offizielle
mitteilung
also malick war aber offiziell von daten
keine dass er als unerwünschte person
erklärt worden ist und dann hat uns
etwas unruhig ja danke wir haben es
aufgeklärt also in dem fall ist herr
melnik der noch botschafter die
handelnde person aber die irritation
macht das nicht gerüstet ich ne danke
bekam von der regierung da bleibt weg
weil du danke danke das ist eingebracht
haben groß nach chemnitz
so jetzt würde ich mal sagen den norden
hatten wir noch nicht gehen dazu
dietrich mateschitz
herzig in unter glinde bei pinneberg
bitteschön ja ja
ich wäre für eine geheimdiplomatie
gesprächen hier mit einer weltmacht und
so wie das jetzt schon auch liegt
politisch abläuft zwischen amerika
westeuropa und russland und auch mit dem
herzen liegt so kommen wir hier nicht
weiter und deswegen
möchte ich die eine frage beantwortet
haben von den herren mit dem grünen
haken was er von einer die
geheimdiplomatie
hält zwischen russland und der
westlichen welt also lange davon der
herr ist mit dem grün jackett ich halte
sehr dass alle bemühungen hinter welchen
verschlossenen türen auch immer die zu
einem ende dieses fürchterlichen krieges
und aller seiner opfer für richtig sind
das ist vielleicht nicht nur zwischen
russland und den usa vielleicht auch mit
china ich sage trotzdem dabei darf
nichts rauskommen was der ukraine in
irgendeiner weise ein ergebnis vor
diktiert was also den verzicht auf
bestimmte territorien und so weiter
betreffen sondern das ziel muss dann
verhandlungen auch zwischen den
unmittelbar kriegs beteiligten zu
ermöglichen ohne dass das ergebnis schon
vorher wird das ist mir wichtig
ansonsten absolut werden solche geheimen
selbst wenn herr schröder bei herrn
putin etwas erreicht hätte in der
richtung wählen wir eben vielleicht
heute alle dann bin ich jemand
information das
dankeschön gibt es daheim diplomatische
kanäle jetzt also es gibt es gespräche
laufen über die türkische seite mit den
ukrainern und mit den russen und ich
würde doch davon waren geheimdiplomatie
ohne die ukraine zu betreiben das weckt
insbesondere polen und anderen aus mit
der europäischen ländern ungute
erinnerungen an 1939 also historisch ist
das schon sehr belastet diejenigen um
die es geht sollten immer mit am tisch
sitzen und
bedeutet geheimdiplomatie hin
geheimdiplomatie her ich glaube putin
ist im moment so stark in der ukraine
leider dass er gar kein interesse daran
hat zu verhandeln er wird vielleicht
scheinverhandlungen führen das kann
durchaus passieren aber er hat kein
interesse daran und insofern
denke ich auch die rolle des türkischen
präsidenten wird oder seinen einfluss
auf putin wird deutlich überschätzt er
hat diesen getreide deal zwar initiiert
aber man muss auch sehen dass putin
daran interesse hatte diesen getreide
deal zu machen weil die afrikanischen
staaten wollte er nicht sozusagen
verärgern ja die standen bei ihm die
haben ihn besucht und gesagt hilf uns
unsere leute verhungern wir kriegen
unruhen und das war sein eigentliches
interesse danke michael helms bedanke
mich auch bei herzig allen anderen die
angerufen haben denn die noten nicht
durchgekommen sind ich finde wir haben
jetzt bei nacht befragt noch ein paar
spannende aspekte gehabt danke dafür und
trotz des themas genießen sie den
sonntag lassen sich gut gehen
stand übrigens stehen
[Musik]